Now, we're going to use a simple
reduction to show that this language B,
consisting of the descriptions of
Turing machines that accept something
is undecidable.
Our strategy is to reduce
the diagonal language to it.
In other words,
we'll argue that deciding B
is at least as hard as deciding
the diagonal language.
Since we can't decide the diagonal
language, we can't decide B either.
Here's one of many possible reductions.
The reduction is a computable function
whose input is the description of
a Turing machine M.
And it's going to build another
machine N in this python-like syntax.
First, we write down
the description of a Turing machine
by defining this nested function.
Then, we return that function.
An important point is
that the reduction,
R, never actually runs the machine N.
It just writes the program for it.
Note here, that in this example,
N totally ignores the actual
input given to it.
It just runs M on it's own description.
And does whatever that computation does.
Hence, and it's either going to be
a machine that accepts nothing,
if M doesn't accept its own description,
either by looping or rejecting.
Or if M does accept its own description,
then N is going to accept everything.
In the one case,
the language of N will be the empty set.
And in the other case,
it will be sigma star.
A decider for this language B, would
be able to tell the difference, and
therefore tell us whether M
accepted its own description.
Therefore, if B had a decider we would
be able to decide the diagonal language,
which is impossible.
So B cannot be decidable.